all right let's hear from some folks in
our audience it's been another
busy week and i want to see what's on
your mind we are now
taking calls via discord you can join
the discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord very very
exciting things happening there i think
we have uh maybe even breached
7 000 discord members and it only
launched
i think it was like somewhere between
two days and seven months ago so that's
that's a lot
let's go first to tim from boston we'll
take a local call tim from boston what's
going on
hey david can you hear me yeah are you
where are you are you at fenway
uh-huh is it bad i'm starting to play
i'm actually near fenway though um yeah
david hey
um so thanks for taking my call um so
you know we saw some big wins uh for
direct democracy with all the ballot
initiatives
uh during the election but i really
wanted to know your opinion on the
efficacy
of this new form of direct democracy
that's becoming popular
i'm working on a website called turk.io
that's t-u-r-q dot io
this website enables everyday people to
collaborate on writing
citizen legislation that then gets
submitted to various legislatures
the idea is that this form of direct
democracy isn't people
voting on every issue rather people
everyday people having a hand in the
actual writing
of the law what are your thoughts on the
efficacy of citizens having a hand in
the drafting of the actual law
um and listen given the fact that uh
given the fact that i don't know
anything about this website are you
affiliated with this website
yes sir you are okay so in the future i
would mention that up front because that
it makes it sketchy when i have to
i have to figure out that you're
actually affiliated with the website
even though it was kind of obvious
because you were like reading off of it
you know
oh my apologies yeah i would say i would
start by saying
i am associated with a website so i know
nothing about the website
here's what i would say given that 72
million people
thought it was a good idea to vote for
donald trump i
question whether letting random people
write laws
is a good idea i am very much for ballot
initiatives i am very much for
you know restructuring our system from
the standpoint of campaign finance
ranked choice voting and all of these
other things letting random people write
laws
to me there's a lot of questions around
that i'd want to think more about it
yeah i mean we see that with the open
source software all the time where you
know we let all kinds of people
participate in writing uh open source
software
we do i think the stakes are maybe a
little different though between making
you know
law and uh writing software well a lot
of open source software is actually used
to keep airplanes in the sky
and and things like that so we a lot of
our infrastructure both from safety and
financial reasons and
in all kinds of ways open source
software is leveraged for those
uh so the idea is that you know citizens
if there's a technology check so that
you know terms of service are met and uh
you know only
the the best quality legislation is
actually you know uh
pulled in and put to use the same way
that you know we process as we see in
open source ledger
in open source software excuse me yeah i
mean i think again the difference with
software is to to even participate in
that process
you need to know how to write software
and the the difference would be
any random person might say hey yeah i
wanna i wanna
write law i think it's an interesting
idea i want to increase the way
i wanna i want to increase the
connection so that
our our elected officials more
accurately reflect
the desires of the people that i do want
whether it's letting random people write
law i'm i'm unsure of but i appreciate
the question
yeah absolutely thanks david and just a
quick plug too to say that you know the
number of people that each individual
representative has to
uh you know account for and write
legislation for uh increases every day
um so that's another reason why this
idea of an alternative direct democracy
where the people can actually
participate in writing
the laws or the legislation for the
things that impact them
is an idea that isn't isn't something i
came up with even though i'm affiliated
with this one website
god's concept of get laws is pretty
popular got it all right very good i
will evaluate its popularity there is
tim from boston
let's go next to becky from birmingham
now is this birmingham
england or birmingham alabama
oh hello david sorry it's birmingham in
the uk oh it is okay i was expecting a
completely different accent
no no definitely the lazy voice if you
hear a lousy voice it's birmingham in
england that's
us now it was just really quickly so
i've got two real questions here for you
so our government have recently voted
against feeding disadvantaged children
during the school holidays as well as
opening all the schools around the
country
almost like a petri dish for the virus
to just mutate around children
how are any of these choices that our
governments are making
how are they helping at the moment and
have you seen anything similar at the
moment in the united
states and the neighboring states in
terms of
taking care of kids who are depending on
on being in school for something like
just even having meals every day you're
saying
yeah so for both um so we have things
here called free school meals
yeah i'm so similar to when children go
to school in the us and have their meals
there as well
right um it's that sort of a feeling
really they've they've not helped out
for
the disadvantaged children who maybe
don't have their laptops at home to work
from home
or maybe don't have the necessary
food allowance to be able to buy that
much food for a week with that i mean
unfortunately there's been no
well-organized federal effort to do that
here in the united states
unfortunately we have this disgusting
reality in the u.s where
it's one of the richest countries in the
world and yet
you still have many kids who are going
to bed hungry you have many kids who are
counting on
getting a free lunch or a reduced price
lunch at school when there's no school
because of the pandemic
what do they do now there have been some
local efforts and i don't have a list in
front of me but there has been there's
been local efforts at the municipality
level
maybe even some at the state level
although i'm not sure to continue
providing the lunches even if there's no
school and i think that that's a great
thing
better would be to solve this problem
where why why do we have hunger in a
country as rich as the united states
but unfortunately nothing nothing um
structural and and federally organized
has been done on that it's
it's pretty sad yeah it's the same sort
of thing here as well there's actually a
famous footballer
um i don't know if it's hit the news
over in the us as well
um a footballer by the name of marcus
rashford has been campaigning for free
school meals
around the uk at the moment to make sure
that these children
are actually getting fed they are
actually
being able to learn on a full stomach
rather than being extremely hungry
during their time
and so there is little things going on
like that but the government have just
declined it really and said no we're not
doing that we'll just throw that to the
side
i do think there are some european
countries that have better dealt with
some of these issues
but but again you know i was i don't
have details in front of me because i
you know i never know what people are
going to ask about but it is um a real
tragedy that this is uh
going on in so many different places
yeah definitely well it has been
absolutely fantastic to speak to you
what do you think that outcome is just
in general of what what could happen in
these situations now just a brief
overview of
will the children ever get fed will they
ever go back to school properly
yeah they will go back to school they
will go back to school but then we'll go
back to still having all of the problems
we had
when the pandemic hit so there's a lot
of work uh certainly
certainly to do um and a bigger topic
for you know an entire show about
education quite frankly but becky i
really appreciate you calling in today
no worries at all it's been lovely to
speak to somebody who knows what they're
talking about so thank you thank you
likewise same same on this side of the
microphone very much appreciate that